ne t'inquiète pas la prochaine fois
qu'on vient tu monteras pas dans le car
pour aller au commissariat tu vas monter
dans un autre truc qu'on appelle une
ambulance pour aller à l'hôpital tu as
fait comment le voyage du Tchad c'est un
titre de séjour tu vas être placé en
garde à vue et demain tu as une aucune
TFC fini coup menace racisme rouler sur
un manifestant ce n'est pas que de
l'inquiétude que nous éprouvons face au
comportement de ces agents de la brave m
à l'encontre des manifestants mais de la
honte de la colère honte de voir de tels
comportements colère de voir que vous
justifiez cela par la fatigue le 22 mars
face à la multiplication des violences
policières de ces agents nous adressons
une demande de démantèlement de la brave
m aucune réponse de votre part monsieur
le ministre allez vous respecter le
droit de manifester mais notamment
démanteler la brave m ou bien allez-vous
continuer de Nasser l'expression
populaire et d'assumer d'être le
ministre de la matraque monsieur le
ministre et j'en termine faudra-t-il un
nouveau Malikou cekin pour enfin vous
faire revenir la raison d'abord quand on
veut dissoudre la bravance ça peut
étonnant parce que ça n'existe pas c'est
pas une unité le problème c'est quoi la
bravem c'est quoi la braven euh c'est
des personnes qui sont des compagnies
d'intervention donc évidemment former au
maintien de l'ordre qui utilise des
motos non pas pour intervenir c'est pour
ça que les parallèles avec des affaires
dramatiques il y a 30 ou 40 ans son nom
outrancier mais insultant et surtout est
totalement ignorant bon et se déplace
pour ensuite intervenir puisque les
manifestations aujourd'hui lorsqu'elles
dégénère et même lorsqu'il y a d'autres
manifestations sauvages qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les manifestations classiques
utilisent désormais beaucoup plus de
mobilité des manifestations chacun le
voit dans leur violence ont changé le
fait notamment de changement aussi du
sens de circulation des pistes cyclables
de la rétrécissement de la voirie les
interventions de la police aujourd'hui
dans Paris ne sont pas de la même
manière qu'il y a 30 ou 40 ans chacun
peut le comprendre puisque chacun pour
utiliser Paris de temps en temps on
constate effectivement ces changements
donc je ne porte d'opinion sur
évidemment ces changements et donc la
victoire du maintien de l'ordre choisir
de l'ordre républicain c'est comment on
va très vite
aussi vite voire plus vite que les
personnes qui
ont décidé de se décomposer un petit
groupe à travers Paris mettre des feux
ici attaquer des bâtiments là la
brassame c'est donc pas une unité qui
intervient en moto c'est une idée qui se
déplace en moto labra même c'est la
possibilité d'utiliser les motos